un grand merci pour ce témoignage de la
réalité vécue sur le terrain vous avez
évoqué plusieurs sujets notamment le
manque de transparence la nécessité de
mieux répartir les marges
j'ai bien aimé votre conclusion et on va
passer le micro à votre voisin il va
falloir faire des choix
merci alors déjà merci au parti des
républicains de nos invités nous
agriculteurs pour venir partager un peu
notre vision économique de notre métier
est de pouvoir peut-être influencé votre
programme pour les prochaines élections
et c'est vrai que c'est c'est quand même
intéressant qu'on partage se nomme de
chose de dire que la crise on avait
toujours toujours je me rappelle
l'invitation c'était la crise de l'été
dernier on est au mois de janvier on est
toujours dans la crise et les paires
cité 2016 ne sont pas très favorables
et comme l'a résumé mawazine je voulais
revenir sur trois éléments quand même de
la crise une crise économique avec des
prix très bas qui fait que écoute les
coûts de production des producteurs ne
sont pas couverts ça c'est le premier
élément
alors en plus est arrivé au cours de
l'année 2015
quelques phénomènes climatiques si çà et
là qui ont provoqué des canicules et
sécheresse importante qui ont aussi
grevé les comptes d'exploitation avec
une gestion calamiteuse du dossier par
le gouvernement
comme vous le savez qui a retiré de 155
millions d'euros sur le fonds des
calamités qui est financé par les
agriculteurs
je crois que monsieur le foll et des
lyrics tendance haussière on comprend
pas trop deuxième chose aussi une crise
sanitaire qui arrivait avec la fièvre
catarrhale ovine qui a aussi plombé les
prix de vente des produits notamment les
expéditions des broutards et des veaux
ont donc de la viande sur l'italie sur
l'espagne hélas aujourd'hui aussi une
gestion calamiteuse du dossier notamment
en janvier où les frontières et
l'espagne se sont fermées parce que
l'administration française je vous le
dis c'est très simple à trouver un
moucheron qui se baladait encore en
france qui se disant est un vecteur qui
paverait propage life ses eaux alors que
ce même boucheron en italie en espagne
il ne circulaient plus il me semble que
l'italie et l'espagne sont un peu plus
au sud de la france mais bon donc voilà
donc de crise économique deuxième crise
comme l'a dit ma collègue crise
normative
on est dans un pays où les vérités
subissent le plus de normes
il n'y a pas une semaine sans qu'il
sorte une nouvelle norme et qui viennent
grever la compétitivité à la fois des
exploitations mais aussi de l'ensemble
de la filière
ce qui pose une vraie difficulté on peut
plus continuer comme cela
certains
députés ont dit faux billets ministre
hâtivement je dirais phobie normative
quoi on est on est un cinéma et tout ça
c'est des normes supplémentaires en
france qui pèse sur la compétitivité et
donc ne nous permettent pas d'être aussi
compétitives que nos voisins européens
un tas d'exemples serait à porter à
votre connaissance je veux prendre et
notamment sur l'emploi
marianne apprentis n'a pas le droit de
marcher de monter sur un escabeau à plus
de 80 cm et même dans certaines écoles
d'agriculture on vous dit que les
stagiaires ils peuvent être dans la
salle de traite à tout le monde sauf
quand les vaches sont là parce que c'est
dangereux bon donc donc mais voilà donc
ces cdd garde qui font sourire mais on
le colle vie quotidienne troisième crise
et catherine l'a dit tout à l'heure
c'est une problématique de remise en
cause du métier d'existence il ne se
passe pas non plus la une semaine sans
que médiatiquement ou quelques
groupuscules et idéologique écologistes
aux réfractaires à la croissance nous
disent il faut plus manger de viande il
faut plus manger boire de l'est le pors
a fait cela le trop de céréales ça fait
cela sa prose est pour l'instant
l'environnement et donc l'agriculteur
qui lui essaye de faire son métier du
mieux possible se retrouve mis en cause
il dit à la fin il pose des questions je
suis représentant du syndicat fnsea
président d'une unité sur les électeurs
quand je les rencontre ces dernières
semaines ils me disent est ce qu'on a
encore besoin de moi et c'est là que ça
pose une vraie difficulté qu'on arrive à
un cocktail explosif des agriculteurs
qui ne gagnent plus leur métier qui sont
remis en cause en permanence sur leur
métier et donc ils disent mais qu'est-ce
qui se passe et donc après on a à gérer
nous syndicats demandent des montées de
fièvre parce que dany lutter ils veulent
tout casser quoi et face à cela un
gouvernement qui ne répond pas vraiment
la question du coût des problématiques
des prix et je finis le là-dessus
pourtant quand on regarde un peu plus
concrètement dans les chiffres
économiquement les éditeurs français
sont performants on regarde dans
beaucoup de production ce sont les plus
performants d'europe
ils ont fait des buveurs compétitivité
très fort ramené au litre de lait par
vache au port je laisserai pas en parler
sur la viande bovine aussi sur la partie
céréalière aussi on a des vraies
performances on a répondu les dangers
des enjeux pardon de société sont la
qualité que sont la garantie sanitaire
donc tout cela on le fait en plus on a
répondu à des d'enjeux de société
française sur l'environnement on ne voit
beaucoup plus loin que d'autres pays et
on est remis en cause tous les jours sur
ces principes là donc ça nous pose une
vraie difficulté ça remet en cause
notre métier et il y en à face à un
gouvernement qui ne répond pas aux
questions qui même au contraire alourdi
la marque le 3 7 ans on avait entendu
des choses notamment il y avait une
porte ouverte sur tout ce qui était
normatif bella porte malheureusement le
25 janvier elle est déjà à moitié
refermer et on n'arrive plus à passer un
certain nombre d'éléments parce que
l'administration française et revenus
énormes et les normes
par exemple le on parlera certainement
de l'emploi ce matin on se retrouve avec
l'emploi avec un conte pénibilité qui
est inapplicable dans l'agriculture
rendez vous compte il va falloir qu'on
contrôle si les métiers qu'on fait faire
à nos salariés quand on en a un
son pénible alors traire des vaches ça
peut être pénible
oui bon ben on conduit un tracteur nous
dit ça peut être pénible ça dépend du
sol
s'il est dur ou mou non non mais ça veut
dire tous les jours on va remplir des
papiers et ça va ça va être la
compétitivé qu'on perd on appareils les
mutuelles qui vont arriver aujourd'hui
ou l'employeur de payer on avait une
volonté sur les mutuelles de dire 50 50
employés employeurs et on se retrouve
aujourd'hui on avait demandé ce que ce
soit des contrats de plus de six mois ou
en rendant la mutuelle où chacun paie là
aujourd'hui on nous dit dès le premièr
heures de travail on va commencer à
payer la mutuelle donc tous ceux qui ont
des emplois saisonniers
je pense qu angélique connaît bien le
sujet vont devoir payer la mutuelle dès
la première heure de travail le salaire
est une journée il faudra payer une
bonne mutuelle
donc c'est tout des choses on a un
gouvernement qui nous disent vous
écoutez je vous ai entendu mais qui dans
les faits ne répond pas dernier point où
on en entend pas ce gouvernement la mise
en oeuvre des compensations financières
européennes de la pac
rendez vous compte les agriculteurs ont
été retardés dans l'instruction de leur
dossier en 2015
ça a été très compliqué nouvelle pac un
ministre qui avait un peu une idéologie
de vouloir modifier l'agriculture partir
d'un bureau parisien en disant voilà je
vais vous oriente et là c'est pas si
simple que cela sur le terrain
nous on s'adapte des besoins de deux
marchés et on se retrouve avec une pac
qui aujourd'hui les habitants ont fait
leur déclaration le 15 juin
en trois semaines ils ont fait sûrs au
travail on se retrouve aujourd'hui avec
20 à 25 % des aides qui ne sont pas
encore payés ou ont ré ouvre les
dossiers de l'ensemble des agriculteurs
on va repasser toutes les parcelles donc
on va retravailler encore des
demi-journées des journées entières pour
faire finir la pac 2015 alors que la pac
2016 devrait déjà et en oeuvre donc
giron on ne comprend plus alors finir
quand même sur un point positif
l'agriculture c'est quand même
essentiel d'un an d'autres pays ça
remplit les assiettes
c'est aussi un repas de qualité il ya un
certain nombre d'éléments là dessus le
seule chose que je vous dis c'est que si
la france ne prend pas les bonnes
mesures
dès à présent j'ai bien peur que dans la
compétition européenne et mondiale de
demain
on ne sera plus présent donc l'enjeu est
primordial c'est rester compétitif et de
gagner aujourd'hui des parts de marché
demain on a neuf milliards d'êtres
humains à nourrir sur cette planète et
on entend bien nos agriculteurs c'est
reparti de ce marché là je vous remercie